(audience cheers)
- I love that we called each other.
- I know.
- And you wear your black.
- We're just like that.
- You even put sparkle in it.
I like it.
You're in a cover band,
so I didn't know this.
- I used to be in a cover band, yeah.
- Oh, you don't do it anymore?
- No, I should get the
band back on the road.
I've been a bit busy.
- I'm making movies.
- I should call up the boys.
- Yeah, 'cause it's all boys.
You were the only girl, right?
- Yeah, I started it
when I was 13 years old.
- Look at you.
- Oh my God. (chuckles)
- [Studio Audience] Aww.
- I really blinged it out.
- I used to have, like,
three of those hats.
Like, in corduroy, it
was like my favorite.
- Oh my god, those were the go-to.
I probably got it from you.
- You probably didn't.
I got it from "Fievel Goes West."
I got it from a movie
that was long before you.
But I loved that, I didn't
know that about you.
It's interesting that you love music
and then you end up in
this role, like, Priscilla.
So what was it like, you're
from Missouri, right?
Coming to Hollywood, that's a difference.
- Oh yeah, that was a
bit of a culture shock.
- Yeah.
It was a crazy sort of
all-American journey.
I was actually performing with the band
at some fall festival,
and then I met a guy, who
knew a guy, who knew a guy
who lived in LA, and we're
like, okay, let's pack the bags.
That was enough for us.
It was like a 25-hour drive
cross-country, me and my mom.
- You have super cool parents.
- Yeah, they really supported me.
- Yeah.
- Stayed in some random people's-
- Shady places?
(they chuckle)
You do what you can, yes.
- Yeah.
And so, that was about four years.
We'd make that trip multiple times a year,
and yeah, four years of nothing, silence,
and I think we were about to give up.
Then got my first role
the month after I was 18.
- What it like?
Kind of a perfect time to get
your first role, actually.
- I think so, too.
- To be 18, and being able
to be more independent.
- I was a little bit older.
- Yeah.
- I felt like that was a
good place to kick it off.
- What was it like?
Were you in Missouri
when you got that call?
- I was, yeah.
I remember I had bad reception.
I couldn't hear them, like, wh-what?
It was the last thing, I
thought I'd lost it, you know?
I thought I blew the audition.
And then I went outside on my driveway,
and then my parents came
out and they were crying,
and they were recording me on their phone.
I just remember, like, the
whole world was spinning.
- That's fun.
- I just called every person
I could on my contacts
to let them know. (chuckles)
- [Studio Audience] Aww.
- That's so exciting.
I did the same thing when I was on a show,
before you were probably born.
But I did, I got so excited.
'Cause it's like your big-
especially if you're from a small town
nowhere near the glitz and the glamour.
- Yeah, you just wanna
scream on every roof-
- Yeah, a mountaintop.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I made it, possibly!
- I did it!
(they chuckle)
- So Priscilla, I love though,
like I was saying, you're into music,
and you end up like playing
this role, Priscilla,
who was with Elvis.
What was it like doing this movie?
- Well it was so special
because, you know, growing up,
I was born in Tennessee,
I was raised in the southern Midwest,
so Elvis was like such
a part of our world.
We grew up going to Graceland,
and Elvis and Priscilla are so iconic,
they're like American royalty.
But I didn't know her side of the story.
- I find that interesting,
I know, I didn't either.
- I know, that was what
was so exciting about it.
I think it's long overdue
to hear her side of things.
- And to see him from a
different vantage point than
most people got to see him.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I think Jacob did a beautiful job.
And to have someone like
Sophia Coppola tell this story,
who's got such a grasp of how to tell it
from the female perspective.
- Absolutely.
- And she doesn't in such a beautiful way.
Her movies are stunning.
- They are aesthetically
so, they're like candy.
- Yeah, they are, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And that world, that
sixties Americana was so rich,
and the colors fashion and...
- Yeah, that's awesome.
We had Jacob Elordie here.
I fell in love with him.
- I know, it's hard not to.
- He's so great.
- He's so sweet.
- So sweet.
Little Aussie boy, I was like,
oh my gosh, he's so sweet.
But one of the things that I-
First of all, how did y'all bond?
I'll ask that question first,
just 'cause y'all didn't know
each other before this, right?
So, you're playing these
intimate roles, right?
- Well, sometimes you get onto set
and it's okay to meet on day
one, just roll right into it.
But playing Elvis and Priscilla,
I knew that we had to have that connection
and had to have that trust in each other.
So, when I found out he got the role,
I was so excited 'cause I loved his work,
but I didn't know how he was gonna be.
So I basically emailed him,
and forced him to hang out
with me and be friends.
(audience chuckles)
(they chuckle)
- You will be my friend.
- I was like, do you
wanna go horseback riding?
'Cause that was something
Elvis and Priscilla loved to do
and he was so game.
- I love that.
- Oh yeah, that's-
- Oh, I've been there, that's on Sunset.
- I know.
- I've done that.
- And the Hollywood sign?
- Yes!
- I've been there, that's so awesome.
But it's kind of hard to
have a conversation though.
- Oh yeah, I know, it was so awkward.
He's like behind me riding a horse.
I'm like, so what- Are you
close with your family?
(they laugh)
In this, like, group
horseback riding trip.
But he was so great,
and he was so connected with the, the hor-
like, he's such a outback Australian.
- Oh, like an animal guy.
- Yeah.
- I love him.
And one of the things I loved
about him that we found out,
is he's an amazing photographer.
My favorite picture he took is of you.
I don't know if you've read your card yet,
but I hope you get a copy of it.
I have to show this picture.
- Oh, I wanna see.
- Oh, this is not one I've seen.
No, no, this is beautiful,
I've never seen that one.
It was another one that we showed.
But anyway, we could show it-
Oh, I've never seen that one either!
(audience laughs and applauds)
- They gave us more.
Oh my god, he is such
a great photographer.
- I know, that was so special.
- There's this one and you
look like a first lady.
It's this one that they
showed whenever he was on.
It's so beautiful, and I just was like,
I hope you get this picture.
He should send this to you.
This should be your Christmas present.
- I just love that he did that,
because we shot the movie in 30 days.
So I sort of have amnesia
when I think back on it.
It's so fun to see those photos,
and it was such a wild
journey we all went on.
- That's a month.
- Yeah, to finish the-
(audience chuckles)
I know, only a month.
- I just got anxiety for
you and it's already done.
I was like, wow, okay.